le département et antenne réunion vous
présente lien social
[Musique]
le département est le chef de file de
l'action sociale
il s'engage auprès des personnes
porteuses de handicap pour les
accompagner au mieux dans leur parcours
à la réunion on dénombre environ 18000
déficients visuels
parmi eux ahmed et cathy avec le soutien
du conseil départemental
ils participent à des activités comme le
cécifoot ou ont accès aux nouvelles
technologies via une structure unique
sur l'île la ccit base
[Musique]
courir feinte et viser des actions a
priori banal pour un footballeur mais
sur ce terrain
chaque joueur réalise une prouesse ces
équipes sont composées de malvoyants
adeptes de cécifoot dany ahmed et leurs
équipiers font partie de l'équipe de la
réunion pour prendre plaisir mais là
pour s'amuser avant tout pour justement
mettre en pratique ce qu'on appelle
entraînements je suis passionné de foot
mais ça m'avait jamais effleuré l'esprit
que c'était possible de le pratiquer en
soi donc la première fois que j'ai
entendu parler de ces disciplines c'est
justement aux jo paralympiques en 2012
[Musique]
les footballeurs réunionnais sont
d'ailleurs sur le chemin des jeux
paralympiques de cette année auxquels
ils vont assister
mais avant ils s'accordent d'une escale
sur la métropole pour une rencontre avec
une équipe nationale et lorsque l'on est
footballeur malvoyants mieux vaut avoir
l'ouïe fine à l'affût des bons conseils
je suis donc beya les buts et je suis
chargé d'indiquer donc aux attaquants
le sens des buts en fait gauche droite
donc éventuellement s'ils sont dans laxe
jeudi axe seule représentante de la
discipline dans l'océan indien
l'association réunionnaise de cécifoot
espère faire découvrir cette pratique et
augmenter le nombre de joueurs
notre but maintenant à venir c'est
justement de développer en fait si vous
voulez dans la zone océan indien
d'autres projets en fait liée notamment
au dégoût cécifoot et à d'autres sports
pour les personnes déficientes visuelles
c'est un peu le note adage s'est
pérennisé développer d'actifs des
sportifs jauge ans que je pratique que
ses disciples pour eux presque ça relève
de l'impossible parce que c'est pas
encore entré dans les moeurs qui sait
pas encore c'est pas encore les gens
monsieur mais je ne parle que des
personnes en situation de handicap peut
faire un sport tout court aux femmes
l'accès au sport mais aussi l'accès à la
technologie
malgré son handicap à saint pierre c'est
ce que propose la ccit base en valois
comme tous les mercredis cathy vient
passer ici quelques heures la structure
offre aux personnes déficientes
visuelles du matériel informatique
adapté pour pouvoir utiliser un
ordinateur une tablette ou un portable
je me suis mise en fait assez
tardivement à l'informatique j'ai
commencé à apprendre avec avec mes amis
et puis un peu tout seul aussi mais en
venant ici j'ai beaucoup appris j'ai
amélioré mais en fait les connaissances
on souhaite en fait nous avoir accès aux
mêmes aux mêmes contenus que vous mêmes
livres ou même
musique aux mêmes recherches que vous
relire les articles en fait ça ça nous
permet de vivre comme tout le monde en
fait
bonjour il ya le talent et la plage
braille
comme ça tu puisse travailler dessus ce
matin j'ai besoin de moi je suis là des
nouvelles technologies pour mym
déficients visuels conçois qu'on y voit
mal ou pas du tout ont constitué un bond
sans précédent en termes de gains dans
notre autonomie dans la vie quotidienne
professionnelle scolaire et et dans
l'accès à la culture à l'information
c'était important de mettre en place un
lieu à la réunion où les personnes
aveugles et malvoyantes puissent venir
découvrir l'accès à l'information la
communication l'accès à l'informatique
un lien numérique mais pas seulement
la ccit base c'est aussi un lieu de
rencontres et d'échangés pour les
usagers cathy profite de cette sortie
hebdomadaire pour retrouver ici tous ses
amis c'est un endroit où tout le monde
se retrouve c'est convivial c'est
agréable
c'est important parce que pour moi ça
fait c'est un jour de sortie parce que
j'ai eu du mal à max a accepté que
j'étais j'ai que j'étais non voyons ça a
été quelque chose de difficile et c'est
au contact d'autres personnes qui sont
dans mon coeur que j'ai appris à me
sentir mieux comme ça inauguré en 2005
la ccit base est un service du conseil
départemental
la structure vient compléter un éventail
de dispositifs visant à accompagner les
personnes porteuses de handicap dans
leur parcours de vie de nos jours lire
un journal lire un livre gérer nos
comptes bancaires
ça fait partie de notre quotidien mais
malheureusement ce sont des gestes très
difficile pour les personnes malvoyantes
et non voyantes
il s'agit donc clairement pour le
conseil départemental de rompre les
seulement de ces personnes
grâce aux accès facilité par les
nouvelles technologies de communication
et d'information on peut s'ouvrir au
monde de différentes manières on peut
être porteur de handicap et s'assumer
dans la vie ordinaire en souffre au
monde à travers la culture à travers le
sport et c'est vrai que avec cécifoot
nous allons voir que on peut aller très
loin et que l'audace l'abnégation ça
paye toujours
quand on veut on peut il nous donne une
très bonne le sens de la vie la réunion
compte 1 à 2% des déficients visuels
soient 18000 personnes concernées afin
de leur permettre d'accéder aux
nouvelles technologies la ccit basent
leur propose un espace numérique publics
accessibles aux personnes malvoyantes
les usagers ont accès à un matériel
adapté et peuvent profiter d'un lieu de
vie et des changes
pour plus d'informations vous pouvez
vous rapprocher de la structure basée
sur saint pierre au 02 62 57 98 27 ou
vous rendre sur le site du département
au www.cn.ca 4 point fr
[Musique]
m